une production du studio sfr bienvenue
sans fil
présenté par kay smil podcast on parle
lorsqu'on vous invitez dati ci-dessus
berges canton avec moi doom plantes
caisse me collabore avec un organisme
qui s'appelle écologie qui s'assure de
planter des arbres un peu partout dans
le monde et à chaque qu'est ce que vous
achetez chez qui un smi en fait ils vont
planter des arbres pour aider la lutte
aux changements climatiques
profitez de notre code promo sans fil
pour 20% de rabais qui contribuent à la
cause cette semaine bien contents de
notre invité dans cette semaine on
reçoit jonathan roy quitte un ami qui
domine ce podcast que vous connaissez
qui chanteur qui dans une autre vie est
un joueur de kingsey grand plaisir de
parler que ségolène qui en vaille
vraiment super relax parce muttsee
toujours ce pas le fun par l'ex colosse
30 schiller professionnels jouent très
très ouvert sur sur la ville va d'esprit
c'était vraiment un grand plaisir de
parler de coup de chaud de relations
nous a parlé de sa dynamique avec avec
sa copine
comment qui fonctionne dans leur coupe
ce qui ce passe par intéressant on
parlait beaucoup de musées que c'est
parce que j'avais lu 6 pi duras et
l'église dernier quand dans un bois de
l'année rami il ya vraiment des vidéos
de ses chansons qui ont explosé sur le
net sur youtube
il se fait connaître mal en ce moment
partout partout dans le monde qui dès
que ça va être possible il valait partir
faire des shows partout ils font fait
que l'on n'est pas chanceux de l'avoir
ici pendant ce temps le on écoute et un
nouveau vidéo réaction
la réaction
des centaines de milliers de vieilles
séries c'est vraiment incroyable c'est
pas cool ce qui fait sens par lucien
seringue hausse par un texte par le fon
à discuter j'espère que vous allez aimer
ça y est on va les remercier nos
sponsors
puis bon voter oui le podcast de cette
semaine et présenté par police lit avec
l'été qui s'en vient vous savez que
l'envi peut vous prendre de partir en vr
de vous acheter un verre partir sur la
route police lit on un matelas fait
spécialement pour le prg plusieurs
features et matelots notamment il ya un
contour de soutien intégré qui permet
aux matelas de perdurer dans le temps
qu'est-ce qui est donc le matelot
derrière pour guillaume mousses anti
microbiens t1 meilleur c'est pas comme
une chambre le savent peu qu'ils aillent
un peu de poussière un peu plus de voix
et vient on y étions
on est dans la nature les oiseaux texas
peur en fait qu'il y avait plus de
bactéries que s'accumulent à votre
matelas c'est pour ceux qui ont une
mousse anti microbienne qui qui réduit
la prolifération de bactéries des
microbes ça c'est ce parcours puis aussi
dans un gars qui peut arriver c'est
qu'ils aient fait que les crimes ne
soient plus hostiles de ses faïences
l'héroïsme à faire c'est celui qui fait
super chaud ça se fasse par froid le
long comme des explorateurs
c'est ce qui se passe avec l'amour ça
leur a permis de régler la régulation
optimale de la surface de sommeil pour
est ce que on donne toujours un
température qui comporte en moins exacts
on va laisser le lien pour se diriger
pour avoir plus d'information au sujet
du matelot vert pour le slip mais on ou
syncope pour vous qui ne s'applique pas
seulement aux matelots vr pour l'islam
mais à tous les produits pour dix lits
c'est le s filtre sj 25s filtre sj 25
ses valeurs valide dis-je du 15 juin
28 dur fait que c'est maintenant allez-y
puis à merci aux gars que j'ai pas fait
legault le poker de cette semaine est
présentée par emma point ca
si comme nous vous commencez à réfléchir
sur votre avenir puis sur une famille
potentiel où vous avez déjà une famille
en fait chic c'est le cas de beaucoup de
gens qui nous écoutent battre c'est
important de penser à advenant qui
arrive quelque chose on touche du bois
qui vous arrive quelque chose vous
voulez pas laisser vos proches vos êtres
chers dans le pétrin pis c'est pour ça
qu'il faut commencer à réfléchir à une
assurance vie mais on sait rome
par où commencer ça nous apparaît comme
quand même compliqué qu'est-ce qu'elle
mois peut nous offrir donne pour nous
aider que m ou 9 900 vie qui est facile
qui pochard que vous pouvez faire par
internet avec votre téléphone chez vous
en pyjama avez vous avez accès à toutes
les réponses à toutes vos questions à au
bout d'un clic si c'est l'assurance vie
c'est quelque chose qui est beau c'est
que si qui est notamment le fun à gérer
mais en vingt minutes à patrick beckham
a pu mesurer la pression de la liberté
et de la paix d'esprit c'est réglé pour
toujours yes fait que allez voir sur
leur circuit sur leur site en fait si
vous même vous savez pas exactement de
quel genre d'assurance des besoins lyon
des techniciens qui vont vous aider à
choisir ce qui vous convient le mieux
donc vous allez pas payer trop quelque
chose dont je n'ai pas besoin je la vois
exactement l'assurance dont vous avez
besoin un fake
allez voir sur leur site puis merci
beaucoup et moi.fr d'encourager le
sans-fil podium
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout un gros gros terrain ouais c'est
gros comme en même temps j'ai 15 à 15 h
10 à ces pogroms et classique que
quelqu'un au centre-ville de marianne
nathan la première fois que tu me cites
est elle pas encore déménagé donne je
pense pas non cotées ou là bas c'était
où c'était j'ai été sur l'île ouen
j'étais dans le vieux mais qui est là
j'aime ça fit avec qui on est cette
offre une place qui fit vraiment ta
personnalité titre une place qui était
parfait pour ma fête on ne trouve une
place qui était pas répondre assez
clairement soit comme tout bon set up
tonton virage les lacs qui peut dormir
des animaux mais comme tout ce que tu
veux c'est ça qu'on se disait autrefois
quand je dis monsieur peut être du
parrot des plans pour les 40 prochaines
années ne s'arrêtera jamais s'arrêter
c'est ce qu'ils font depuis défaut je
commence à faire des enfants plus qu'en
franche pour effacer d'un trentaine de
quoi d'autre mais ça fait ça ça me tente
en face b lance bien des
de travailler sur le confinement
starcraft c'était grave tout le monde
quelque part indiqué moussa me permit de
me perdre là-dedans
la pandémie dans le fond de ton et
étaler la journée toutes fermées nous
autres on allait signer le papy pour
avoir la maison dans la journée que te
faire mais qui le lie à le louer un
genre de troc un petit troquet comment
taper sur les petits troquets la home
depot commence à parler petit pick-up ci
dessus du sol plus cette douce 12 pieds
10 m eur puis à paname et on sait on à
5h arrêter vraiment c'est tout on ne m'a
de la maison 1,5 hors d'usagé puis ça
fait beaucoup de choses à faire par
exemple mais a été vite ça fait du bien
parce que ça fait du bien d'arriver le
pis avant parce que je suis je t'ai
j'avais mon sac mon sac à dos sur le
bord du diagma chez ma femme fait que si
je tapote chez boulanger ça j'avais
juste l'avant depuis l'amendé la vente
d'un délit a voulu quand même être qu'on
doute être au centre-ville pour sa job
te fait que jusqu'à peu trouble on ne
restait 2 3 en avant non peut on peut
sortir de là un petit peu plus et la
douche ou citer deux trois ans va pas
vendre
ailleurs il ya un va et vient au québec
ouais ok
donc il n'y avait pas vraiment de place
ou fallait sortir du québec mais dont
pour pour bien dormir parce qu'on compte
de lanvin fait que lys va jeter content
d'être dans un conduit aussi en même
temps puis je pouvais pas voyager parce
que je travaillais mais ça a été
magnifiquement celle femme partira à
vendre une plus forte on a parlé de tout
pays si le 2010 peut-être presque partie
un acte à moto sur un goal bien chez
nous mais y arriver que certains son
petit matelas gonflable les foulées fois
que je suis venu chez vous par la
pandémie que je dormais à m'attendre
c'est comme moi si c'est un os que
georges je veux juste sortir de la ville
du tout tu imagines tu te sens chez vous
la maison ouais ça tu t'es suédois parce
que parce que c'est quand même un petit
chat à chaque fois chardome gamins du
tout la ville pour pas tout non non non
mais oui perche mais nie pas qu'un
plancher voulait pas le vendre et dim n
b nerveux de la semaine des dancings
vivier merle
le panier les petits massages l'autre
soir jégo avait joué de ma vie' quand tu
arrives ben kattra parfait j'imite en
massage à cette excuse moi je découvrais
j'allais jallet rien rajouter à ça et tu
disais tantôt même que c'est important
d'avoir une place qui te ressemble qui
le je te connais plus la dernière fois
qu'on était venu sur le podcast pas mal
plus en fait pire honnêtement même temps
raison quand je suis de connais toi je
connais pas je tiens ta femme aussi pesé
comme crise qui c'est chez vous semaine
ça fait du sens le tri qui allait les
clés chien peut sortir courir partout
même qu'ailleurs le cheval qui est le
manga chantier c'est ça c'est fermé
anglais d'un cochon est un cochon dix
poules lapins puis l'a d'ailleurs on
vient d'avoir le full certificat dans
les salons dit l'attendre il je postais
pas des vidéos de la femme parce que je
vais pas mettre dans le trouble noyer
plus montrer aux gens soumission
instagram
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on est
en train de bâtir mais c'était juste
pour toi ou tu veux avoir un côté
commercial atteinte non non je suis
juste pour nous d'être suffisamment away
avec votre but c'est de vivre le plus
possible indépendance
on aimerait ça ma femme en fait si c'est
plus c'était plus la ram afin d'être
complètement auto suffisant puis maujean
à bagdad
je trouve ça je trouve ce cochon saint
martin je veux c'est motivé par ce par
quoi a fait part qu'elle est pour moi
une sentir bien et je trouve ça cool de
savoir qu'est-ce que je m'engage à ce
que qu'est-ce que je les ai pas tous
d'abord sochi nous aussi posé nadal ou
au magasin pogné masse boulette mes
carottes ou seule femme d'abord ça chez
nous dans mon jardin puis tu suis pas
prêt nécessairement à manger me poule
mai à nîmes ou encore sont par l'épi
setaf parce que je suis vraiment content
accrue altéad animal mais en même temps
six mois maintenant à la maison je donne
normand d'amour et s'anime à cet animal
l'appui je me sens bien que j'ai donné
il me redonne quelque chose
tandis que d'acheter le mythe est
dérangé ou maxime godart baisse
c'est pas tout le temps su pas ce qui se
passe avec des animaux dans les nasses
et environnement le raf la façon qu'ils
sont traités
c'est une bonne idée nous autres
chrétiens ont du pognon crise de belvis
fait que ces méthodes cochon avec à
l'époque pour ce conte au titre de la
facilité à manger de la viande des
connaissances et plastiques deux jours
maaf d'alpha on a une vie bien que ça
peut être d'école puis chargé tapis
aveu manger tout même sac à le manger
une poule où jones puis le liliane
atteint par a pleuré par milan on peut
pas laisser ça de même au chômage allait
comme forme ce bois là brûlée par un
genre de petites mini cérémonie puis là
je me suis dit ah non tu aimes tu vas me
dire de cuisine me manque la moitié du
coût pour petit doigt me dit ah
après sur youtube comme un fantôme de
mouches en avant de la scène c'est
apprendre à monter un mur bien faire de
la plomberie dans la zone des plumes et
faty tu as raison c'est s'ils ont
tellement préparés sont au repos comme
une fourre bec comme il faut de cette
façon je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'entre
nous parce que évidemment le sait on si
on veut plein d'athlètes tout de suite
fait aussi mais a love me do in
transition afin de mon côté
éventuellement je vois faire la pole le
cuisiner je veux des gardes à mort
attendent ici si je l'avais su si c'est
moi qui leur ai dit que la taille du
fait de la façon que le format audio est
peut-être que je me sentis qu'aurait
callamand gmail est comme je la ramasse
un petit manger par mon chien je
vraiment la viande est raide aussi parce
que tu es
fax et lili tout fait pour le manger à
la ceeac y est je pense que de manger un
peu mais je la voyais aller d'après m a
changé j'ai grandi sont en rade
puis un mets mes bons amis encore
aujourd'hui il y avait une ferme puis il
y avait les l'épaule puis on les tuait
je me rappelle des images même j'étais
jeune pour faire ce genre d'affaires la
mêlée paul pendu par les pieds tu te
promènes claque branche lagrange la
gorge que ça fait je suis ses créateurs
encore aujourd'hui mais ces images là
mais j'étais petit pitch convenait pas
trop ce que je trouvais ça une scène
qu'on faisait le puits c'est aussi une
scène le pilote mais j'aurais su
j'aurais la mise en béton puis pendant
longtemps j'ai fait de la dissociation
là je me suis dit mettons le poulet que
j'ai acheté à l'épicerie ce n'est pas le
même que je trancher la gorge et oublie
ça plus pauvres sinon j'aurais eu de la
misère plus compliqué quand même rester
6e mais si je pense que dans le bon
vieux temps quand c'était bien fait
puisque mon stand game où sa succession
on abuse de de ce qu'on fait on n'abuse
pas mal les animaux c'est celle-là je
pense qu'on abuse de tout aussi fictive
on n'est pas parce qu'on est tellement
intelligent pions parce que l on
trouvera d'autres solutions mais je sais
que d'énergie à savoir où la raison
pourquoi qui ont travaillé pour boxer
[Applaudissements]
mais le seul problème qui va arriver par
exemple aussi avec karl cachent des
places pour les batteries de batterie -
avec le lit se sont en train de corriger
des défauts rebih s'est faite faut
qu'ils trouvent les alternatives je
pensais même de l'électricité y at il
des engins vraiment à ce même si c'est
gris droid aux green bay d'eau des
barrages qui apparaît sur des
communautés locales et autochtones qui
habite cet art qu'est ce qui est
inquiétant c'est vous encore les
symboles mais qu'est ce que tu fais si
tu participes t on leur suivre deux
semaines jean martin sorti le dalphond
lycéens d'un agriculteur bio de
proximité qui appelle avec une enfant en
cause de ces revues la toupie ta femme
va les tripes et l'insultaient doit plus
qui était qui fait pousser des enfants
lui dans le fond il ya un terrain de 1
ha se connectant qui a créé une ferme là
dessus vous possédez des légumes puis
redoux ça rentre vraiment ultra rentable
avec des techniques 200 meilleurs il
vend 200 mails via chaque seconde de
légumes avec le nectar qui cite des
techniques rien de tilly aucun cri
machinerie ou qu'un tracteur avait
beaucoup de projets mais pas si tout
fait à de façon artisanale
ça marche full tilt lui il dit si tout
le monde faisait comme comme lui comme
toi dans le fond environnementalement
joseph andré tout mais ce serait une
révolution
s'il ya plus de monde qui retournent
leur veste longue préface certain mais
il y est les places qui commence à faire
des genres de jardin sur le toit des
victoires qui se bat comme un rasoir
persuadé qu'on est en train d'écrire
ces 8 millions de personnes à peine
qu'il n'en voyais arriver n'est pas
sicav que ça non plus toi tu quand même
tu l'appelles du retour à la terre mais
temps de sortir de la ville d'aller
s'installer quand même loin d'un centre
urbain pitié d'avoir ta place mais ça
c'est pas quelque chose que beaucoup de
gens notre génération peut-être
peut-être que c'est un avis loin mais je
pense pas que c'est tout le monde qui en
a qui aspirent à sauter puis vite il ya
quand même quelque chose dans la vie
urbaine ces mêmes
même moi je ne sais pas si je serai
prête c'est à habiter ou est-ce que tu
habites c'est même si le spot est une
sainteté tencent sauf que je sais pas si
je serai prêt à cette offre beaucoup de
monde parce que la job et 6 mai mais je
pense qu'on le réalise avec le coville
qui tout le monde est à maison de mon
travail à la maison ça fonctionnait très
très bien on réalise que les gaffes et
ses zones à bully needed mon métier mais
ton parce que le seul on réalise en ce
moment mais j'ai l'impression que quand
ça va réouvrir on veut réaliser aussi
que aller un resto avec des dom c'est le
fun à l'e10 promener dans le temps le
soir d'été c'est autant christie fait
que comme ça aussi qui tentera une
social loin c'est sûr peut-être que
l'idée c'est d'avoir évidemment c'est
ultra privilégiés de pouvoir même pensé
à cette réalité là mais c'est d'avoir un
appart en ville puis un chalet parce que
tous les chalets oui moi je socialise à
la maison c'est moi je prends gars qui
aime nécessairement aller d'abord pipi
type me saouler
j'ai pas beaucoup de face j'adore je
suis rendu à une autre étape dans ma vie
puis j'ai besoin je suis beaucoup mon
fils je pense que ce sera le à 50,9 lors
sortir de la ville y ont fait leur
affaire d'envié ni aux three lions ne
sont plus ils veulent peut-être une
petite vie plus tranquille métier
j'adore amener mes amis à maison pipi
cette femme sa fille et puis dans un
endroit où police et 40 pour les gens
aux six mois jeudi john décence de
raison d'être en ville pour aller
prendre une bière ou pas d'à côté et
puis prendre c'est de trouver si le
baril après un pic du fait des erreurs
c'est à erreur partout pullman et de
soja diab un fuck thx et des stocks de
distillats tranquillement je pense que
c'est ce que les légumes en fait on ne
monte travailler sur nous autres pour
trouver une piste est un genre de
petites bulles czink hon volant je pense
qu'on ne savait pas qu'on allait la voir
maintenant à 30 2 1
parce qu'on aurait passé un petit peu
plus tard mais gagne préfecture une
pause puis ça marche bien avec le style
de vie qu'on a pu avec la musique
battait tout en voyage je travaille un
peu à l'extérieur tout le temps fixé
j'ai pas besoin de travailler des dettes
au centre vient nécessairement pour pour
ma job fait que c'est fini dit ça mais
ma femme m'a aussi fiq
ça tombe bien fait quand même temps que
j'attends ça fait 5 puis dans toute
cette recherche de trouver qu'est ce
qu'on veut il y avait toujours la
constante de on veut être ensemble parce
que tu mets ton moi je dis maintenant je
fais mon moment mon voyage spirituel le
outils du - mark mc ait ma recherche de
connaissances dessous connaissance de
moi puis d'essayer de découvrir mettons
qu'est ce que tu dis le farceur j'aime
pas ça puis mais il ya toujours juste
mon ma propre personne dans l'équation
t'ai jamais de en ce moment en tout cas
dans la vie tu sais j'ai pas cette
question là de me dire ok mais est-ce
que ça plaît aussi maintenant quelque
chose que j'aime qui s'appelait aussi à
la personne avec qui je veux dans ma vie
comme de quoi de plus dans l'équation
j'ai l'impression vous êtes a toujours
été je déteste qu'on fait ensemble puis
on les traverse en sens où c'est comme
moi je fais tout moi je fais mon test
quant à spi ça donne qu on se rejoint
dati je fais ma vie elle fait sa vie
puis on se supporte dans nos vies de
titres mon équipe de saint paul les
choses que lily veut pas faire ben ali
fait preuve les choses que je peux faire
et glee
j'ai fait la valeur qui a fait un pari
de votre relation vraiment êtes vraiment
en ligne et non sens qui est ici et je
pense qu'au niveau des valeurs niveau du
style de vie et plein de choses qui fit
naturellement si vous êtes comme trouver
un bon marche le pilote honda fonctionne
nous dire comment vous voulez vivre
cette attitude même où il ya eu des
périodes où est ce qu'il y avait un
décalage l'absolu mais mon noeud comme
n'importe quelle relation qu'on a eu des
hauts et des bas puis même durant la
confinant on a eu quand même moment que
cette étoffe
il m'a aussi que cette étoffe
c'est avant qu'on achète la maison si
c'était pas acheter une maison ensemble
puis de vraiment jump et d'empathie de
life puis des fois surtout dans la
société ou convient bien des fois on
voit sur papier aussi plus on n'a pas
parce qu'on est rendu qu'on attendait
deux enfants de la maison que l'on n'a
pas parce qu'on est plus heureux puis on
ne sait pas si on devrait rester ou
partir mais l'on sait que le
portefeuille voire mal où les enfants
blessés
buffet en plus en plus toi tu comme un
modèle d'un divorce que comme un loup
était mal mais en même temps oui mais
dans la maison ça tout temps était
magnifique et j'ai été chanceux de voir
quand même deux passant de s'aimer
jusqu'à temps qu'ils savaient puppy que
c'était fini mais non les documents même
j'aurais jamais pensé de dette avec je
me disais que j'allais pour trouver
quelqu'un pour un petit bois
finalement je pense que je t'ai trois ou
quatre ans célibataire puis j'avais été
comme blessé un peu pas mal d'années
relation on me parle un petit peu puis
je pensais pas trouver quelqu'un il
parle des indépendants que moi je t'ai
indépendant puis on s'ajuste
parfaitement notre besoin d'être parfait
mais c'est parfait pour ce qu'on a
besoin nous sommes les films je trouve
ça les films je pense que vous passez
d'être serein mais je n'ai pas senti le
cinéma du zoo mis en image d'amour celui
du pauvre on a parlé on a parlé
récemment avec une naïveté qui a fait un
essai la turquie qui parle que de ceux
d'à quel point et mettons les en
dissuade hameau dans les fictions les
comédies romantiques ceci irréaliste
voire d amour même toxiques sont
vérifiées l'utiliser thèse d'histoire
c'est justement tout ça était naturel ça
a été et est facile dans un sens même si
des boots of métissé comme si la mode et
on s'arrache le coeur puis c'est du
style pinana mais c'est comme si c'était
l'amour le plus plus vrai
les gens embarquent souvent à des
relations comme avec un personnage qui
crée pour cette personne c'est normal
c'est comme une protection qu'on se fait
pour pour que ça marche puis nous on ne
[Musique]
fait tellement dating d'arriver plus tu
dis quelque chose je ne peux pas dire
c'est à juste essayer de trouver le
sweet spot que l'autre mais finalement
tout si elle est à vire folle où tout ce
vieux fou sur un sujet dès le début
c'est à dire que c'est une fausse
relation cette espèce de désaccord là
que tu parles si c'était pas d'accord ce
quelque chose de juste pas d'accord
c'est quelque chose de lo'jo l'autre
chose j'avais une conversation avec les
lic était quand même relevé où est-ce
qu'on est en désaccord par rapport à la
vaccination n'est pas parce que chez
qu'il y était pas nécessairement pour
nécessairement les vaccins pour un
médicament pour elle et se pourrait
qu'on avait comme un argument le thé
autour de ça puis la seconde ce qui est
le sujet a changé il n'y avait aucun
chantait aucun droit auquel aucun fois
comme si on avait comme si on venait
parler du shopping en avait mangé
puisqu'elle allait mais pop puis moi je
l'aimé tant puis après ça c'était fini
ses jours
elle avait la même vision je chantais
qu'elle avait le même regard sur moins
que je avant cette conversation la sauce
erreur dans société
serrar avait vraiment voir que ok on
n'est pas d'accord sur ce message change
rien sur la cité reste quand même comme
personne devrait très vite les aigus
pourquoi ça serait toute plate un monde
où tout le monde était d'accord ça
serait de la marque cherche tout ce je
trouve ça hyper important de
l'acceptance de m1 du team dessoude
rating de soins médicaux si oui il ya
des affaires ça va arriver le maton
lydie à walter avant me dira pas
d'accord même temps la desserte
il faut que je plie dévoué mais ccsa
fait partir des fois qu'ils sont faux
fait on n'est pas contre sacrifices pour
les gens qu'on aime puis je tousse
tousse important de truies ram albalad
d'apps et s'étoffe c'est une ration
citerne
c'est à fillon en 2021 je trouve que oui
oui en même temps c'est parce que dans
le tas y avait comme la religion kikito
retenait de sortir d'une relation
c'était vraiment mal vu plus aujourd'hui
baisse moins en moins de monde qui
croient en dieu quand le kit fait
clairement le monde ce divorce ici
gauche qui compta en date samedi
mais moi je suis vieille école ou que
our work a marqué les plus belles
relations qu on a en a mis à mort des
bébés c'est que traverser des hauts et
des bas au pit d'envoyer chier puis wade
route a vécu toute la patente
parce que c'est l'autre de la vraie
relation c'est pas du flamand qui sont
en fait qu'un exemple qui sont jamais
chicane et d'abîmer
un autre progresser dans cette
thématique le sujet qu'on parle beaucoup
tu avais en fait ensemble tout - c'est
sur la conception du couple commettant
couples monogames quelque chose que moi
je de conversations en conversation je
commence à remettre en question de plus
en plus par pas nécessairement par
rapport à mes relations parce que je
sais pas encore exactement si c'est
quelque chose que je serai confortable
afin d'avoir un coût plus vers une
relation ouverte mais je sais que ce que
je sais pour un fait c'est que c'est une
construction sociale
ce c'est sûr ça c'est quelque chose qui
nous conte qui a été construit cette
conception là d'un cowboy ou de langue
séminole la sexualité est pile qui l'a
la mort étant de savoir li c'est ça
c'est quelque chose qui ait construit
parce que je n'ai pas de raison logique
pourquoi ce serait ça mais tant pis
comment est-ce que ça s'articule toi
comment ça s'est articulé maintenant
cette espèce de compréhension de caisse
qui commentent comment tu tentes revoyez
les relations parce que tout pas
toujours été dans des relations ouvertes
dans ta ville puis j'étais blessé du
pain ou ne pas en parler mais qu'est ce
que ça a était quoi ton cheminement par
rapport à cette question le pastiche et
que c'est quelque chose qui intéresse de
plus en plus les gens à nos autres stars
on a des questions par rapport à seul et
les podcasts ou est-ce qu'on en parle
justement de sucer des podcasts qui sont
vraiment écouté puis c'est quelque chose
qui c'est quelque chose qui est dur à
comprendre
considérant qu'on a grandi dans cette
conception l'homme et wassa et écoutons
parcours puis moi je pense que ces
écoutes moi j'peux te parle ton
expérience à mon expérience c'est que ça
s'est fait vraiment naturel puis
je me dis je sais que moi je dit en
avoir le goût de mets ton d'aller voir
ailleurs ou je veux tout en haut le goût
de rencontrer d'autres mondes puis c'est
la même chose je pense pour elle aussi
c'est si ça s'est fait naturellement une
façon qu'on voulait juste ça fait du
bien d'être tellement petit pas de
sentir comme ça donne ce qu'il veut puis
moi je dois pas ce que veut ce que je
veux à noter que du respect puis qui a
pas de mensonge puis je trouve que le
monde le monde maniement beaucoup en
relation puisque hd à faire puis j'ai
pas de givrand par goût de gaulle de les
voir quelqu'un puis je n'ai pas à ma
femme à los angles date je trouve ce
plat pis je veux vivre une relation que
c'est complètement honnête et je trouve
que c'est naturel d'avoir le goût de
vous que ces [ __ ] cet ancien c'est
pas tout le temps évident c'est un ça
peut être très difficile même parfois
mais faut que tu as énormément je pense
confiance en ton amour et il faut que
tout de suite en confiance c'est en tout
cas je pense
puis moi je me dis mais celle ci a même
pas aussi comment t'y as many changes
pas hp paul leur tenir compte ses envies
sexuelles ou ses envies de quoique ce
soit
après semaine je peux pas contrôler
si ça va ça va voir ailleurs puissent
défense mais tellement près sans moi je
suis je m'ennuie tellement je pense
c'est peut-être pour ça que j'ai comme
virer de l'eau côté je me suis dit oh
regarde où habitait dans la can pour
pâques à part puis je pense cisma dans
les relations avant avant les listes un
peu ce puis j'avais pas dessus puis
avoir été blessé par parce qu'elle est
allée voir quelqu'un d'autre ça me comme
je pense à moi je me suis dit waouh je
suis désormais bicchisano puis après ça
ben je laisse je laisse les choses aller
un petit peu proche pour contrôler les
sentiments d'une personne qui a pris le
dessus et ce que vous avez établi
mettons des règles claires où tout se
fait naturellement puisqu'il ya eu ce
qu'ils arrivent puis d'autres titres
vous en discutez payer somme et on
parlait l'homme est sûre on peut parler
le ton on en a discuté avant dans le
fond c'est sale évoluent à changer une
fois ça dépend aussi de la personne ça
dépend t toupin la femme et on gagne
tout dans le respect puis on se parle
pilon d'un faux faux faux évidemment
comme je te dis à l'aise avec soi même
et avec l'amour et avoir confiance aux
coupes
je pense que c'est ce beaucoup de monde
en fait qui sépare aujourd'hui parce
qu'on qui ont le goût d'aller voir eyong
de tripes et d'abord les comme du genre
du jeu on peut les appeler comme les
papillons le début le temps mais les
greens des grâces pis moi c'est sûr que
pour moi pis pour les lis je pense qu on
est bien comme ça puis on va se garder
ça jusqu'à temps peut-être les enfants
vont changer notre relation tacon volant
est beaucoup plus fermé mais on aime ça
comme ça puis on trouve ça on trouve ça
l'fun sa garde un peu de gym un peu de
magie d'un coup si la pression que le
déficit trouve
et quelqu'un avec qui sait l'envi cette
envie le est égal maintenant le tpiy que
c'est vraiment les deux qui ont désiré
la même façon on s'est pris dans des
relations ça arrive des fois qu'il ya un
déséquilibre de 1 peut-être un peu plus
attachés à l'eau tout en plus envie
d'aller voir à la lie à l'autre - on est
un petit peu plus jaloux claude zidi
ça arrive souvent souvent des fois ça
switch même dans une relation période
c'est l'autre mais d'être vraiment 100%
égal à 100%
aussi bien dans le type de couple qu'on
choisit ses seules des fip j'imagine
c'est si rare tu le dis à personne n'y a
pas de raison qu'ils étaient voués à des
fluctuations absolument psychologue
mettons que kelly aime non monsieur peu
confortable contre ben laden et sur des
gros gains plus importants la relation
que j'ai avec elle que que la scrap et
pour une soirée avec quelqu'un d'autre
j'ai l'impression que ça ça doit partir
plus de temps c'est mettons pour être
confortable dans ce même si la relation
est pas balancé dans la vie de chacun
des partenaires je pense que ça port
strelok de toile
si toi maintenant des 100% confortable
faut que je trouve quelqu'un qui l'est
aussi avec elle même et avec l'idée qui
est maintenant la fiscalité puis l'amour
et pas lier le tout je pense qu'il faut
juste que sa part de trois meetings
parce que tu laisses plus âgés la mare à
l'expliquer parce qu'on sait c'est
tellement naturel et kelis voilà des
sahwa qu'il n'y a pas de faits je pense
que c'est quelqu'un sans vauvert seul à
voir un couple voir avec la personne
mais c'est parce que ça s'est fait
naturellement c'est comme une pie x il
ya new tech mais il y en a qui vont le
faire pour sauver leur coupe ça marche
en a qui le font parce que déjà joint
venture mais faut vraiment tu le fasses
pas ce que ça vous fait du bien puisque
c'est comme ça que ça va passer
faut que ça va être la relation ses
nuits à laval
la relation puis tu as raison je pense
de plus en plus les gens se retrouvent à
ce gouvernement parce que comment
expliques tu mets ton comment tu parles
de ton expérience encore une fois mais
jamais été un proche même que ce thème
souvent moi qui se fermaient à l'idée
maintenant quand l'idée est d'amener sa
table c'est la confiance
ou juste dans ses valeurs mais c'est
correct aussi jean mus était
probablement plus mon orgueil hockey de
pas sentir que je t'ai assez
possiblement que c'était ce qui était
attaqué fondamentalement mais après ceux
où est ce que je voulais en venir en
disant que moi ça a toujours été moi que
tu as peut-être un petit peu plus fermé
à l'idée jeux capables de rationaliser
mettons quand ils l'expliquent comme ce
jeu me dit ça fait le sens du monde
parce qu'ils m'ont la valeur numéro un
c'est l'honnêteté la valeur numéro un
c'est l'honnêteté même que pour moi la
sexualité c'est pas c'est pas dans le
top des trucs nécessaire dans une
relation si nécessaire
mais c'est pas dans mon top c'est une
bonne affaire qui arriva en se mettant
dans qu'un pylône était si dense tout
petit puis on dirait qui a expliqué
je capable de le rationaliser puis je me
dis ça fait du sens même ça fait du sens
pis potentiellement que dans une
relation éventuellement je vois capable
de plus les essayer par ou du moins de
l'amener satam et meci ça mais on dirait
que c'est comme un peu un processus de
com de déconstruire parce que je pense
c'est sur ce passé des contrats la
relation est ce que tu avais la
discussion puisque les deux vous êtes
d'accord sur le fait que ce corps est
que une aventure de temps d'entamer
temps ci dessus en guinée près village
que tu utiliseras privé
je l'aiderai cette carte là car oui oui
c'est vrai que ça soit motivé d'un par
la vie mais c'était même pas cette envie
le nom mais oui oui ça m'est arrivé
d'être en coupe puis d'avoir des soirées
où est-ce que moi c'est ce que c'est
c'est maintenant la halle à l'acte
sexuel m c'est l'écho il s'est quand
même c'est comme la cerise sur le sundae
de quelque chose de grand
je ne veux jamais avoir un mètre avec
quelqu'un que je rencontre afin dans un
bar à 3 heures il fallait bien chez nous
là ça va être une soirée que je passe
avec quelqu'un qu'on trip qu'on vend
même connaissant même longueur d'onde
piccule c'est comme elle elle s'est
juste comme la fin c'est la fin
naturelle à la soirée s'est donc c'est
pas purement sexuelle tu es donc c'est
lié à autre chose non mais c'est lié à
une connexion puis une connexion
éphémère c'est parce que c'est ce qui
est arrivé c'était des one night quand
même que je peux parler à ces personnes
le lendemain ou outils je leur parlais
m'épate c'est ça la différence entre pu
- là dessus c'est que moi je vais pas
les 100 membres une connexion avec
d'autres personnes comme tout savoir pic
ce soir c'est qu'un préfet dé mon jeu on
se rend compte en chine il ya une belle
chimie et 9 6 équipes samedi pour le 13e
bale pas d'aller faire du du carrosse
dans le vieux québec
c'est carrément un bon triple c'est
comme un bon moment ça se finit comme
social ce que je vois c'est une
connexion d'une sourde ses pommes pour
jean rey
et on se voit une fois qu'on s'entend
s'en va de suite après s'être salue le
teen peas mais pas l'un vers ce de jaar
une dette avec du vent il le sait pas
vraiment sur le tri mais maintenant
c'est sûr moi je m'imagine pour dire
genre ça serait quelque chose qui ne
pourraient ne pas déranger mon couple
une soirée comme seule excuse mines par
le cahier intime et on mettra je me dans
la position de ta blonde éventuel
sachant comment tout fonctionne pour que
tu as eu envie d'une relation sexuelle
avec quelqu un fauteuil une connexion
puisse passer une belle soirée
c'est plus inquiétant quelqu'un une
belle soirée maintenant mais c'était une
connexion après ça ça se fait ça c'est
c'la faut que tu as confiance à ben
c'est d'être vocal quelque chose mais on
doit tuer le moi je trouve ça moi je
trouve ça c'est comme ça à l'idée fois
parce que des fois maintenant on va
rencontrer quelqu'un pas dix ans je peux
pas faire ça c'est pourquoi je pense
parce que d'après moi je vous dis que ça
ça marche ça marche bien six mois c'est
peut-être une passion pour le parachute
non mais je le saurai jamais tant que
j'en fais porter puis ça me dérange
repos tant que les précédents moi ce que
tu fais du parachute va avoir de quoi de
nouveau dans ta vie qui va être foré
mixte empile phone pour toi une nouvelle
passion se découvrir et aurait jamais
découvert c'est plus de 100 traitements
je le vois c'est comme je l'aimé pas de
parachute mais si je vois en forme et je
découvre que c'est la chose numéro un
que je veux refaire tout le temps même
fait du parachute mais je sais qu'ils
avaient les religieux de bacon ne
devrait pas se retenir pour pour
certaines capacités je comptais me temps
lily je la comprends aussi aller en
boîte kwapis aveu pas ce cap et ça aussi
que je la comprend aussi des fois brest
au filet
et fort ils devraient être correctes a
exposé une dette qui va changer tout ce
qu'on lit dans une boîte c'est moche moi
je crois vraiment à ce psy c'est que ça
passe ça valait pas la peine mais qui
sait c'est probablement parce qu'il
fallait que mathieu may be j'imagine
baby mais je comprends donc nous aussi
des fois c'est parce qu'ils étaient
défendus tatry par la nouveauté comme tu
dis tantôt le gloss fait part à 6 à doha
de la dombes est incroyable passé sous
ce qui est nouveau ce qui est frais
puisqu'ils et cessa de la beauce à leur
incroyable mais au final de ce que tu
avais le tester ça peut être une année
de calvaire pour tout le monde le titre
et non non absolument falloir un plus
beau plus tu as parlé puis mène ces
figures de style en procès se soucie
puis faut que tu sois puis nous on a un
bar qui donnera là dans notre relation
comme sosa a été mis au clair parts à un
fake
d'après moi ça doit être complètement
différent quand ça fait coupe
d'anecdotes ensemble puis bon tu veux te
lancer là dedans ça doit être quand même
je pense ça doit être quand même bref ça
prend c'est un est preuve de donuts et
transparence que tu as soir après cinq
ans de relation farges arrêt est défini
nos codes
c'est quand même skyrock n roll ouais
mais c'est ce cadre est si on ne reçut
un couple de semaines julian qui a fait
exception deux piquets qui aurait pas
carton sans pitié pour les deux je vais
essayer une option parce que vous retire
la sexualité puis l'amour c'est une
seule et même chose pour ma guerre on
est même pas mais maman puis comblement
compte c'est notre petite épicerie en
bout de ligne
chacun fait ce qu'il veut prête à y
renoncer
seuls sont touchés par un port qui est
capable d'une action qui va avoir un
impact mettons sur d'autres je dis tu
fais ce que tu es d'environ 6 pour ce
qui est des concepts comme je mets ton
exemple l'homophobie sauf à le
comprendre
oil uk sur toi moi qui te couches qu'est
ce que tu fais du site
tu fais ce que je veux je fais ce que je
veux tout le monde est content puis même
chose c'est ce qu'ils étaient un couple
ouvert aucun si ce jeu ça regarde
quelques jeux content pour tous les
férus abitibi
biache cobra pour ça d'ailleurs manque
encore aujourd'hui on fait pour ses
affaires comme le moins faux habits
bizarrement comme ça c'est dur à
comprendre
cela revenait pas sur toi mais je pense
que notre génération vous même dino kidd
kidd nommer la nouvelle génération sans
vovard certains pays je pense les gens
nous s'ils commencent à se parler
beaucoup plus souvent
je trouve comme le mythe du mouvement
énormément aidé les choses aussi de fo
est en salle à l on est à l'aise paraît
plus de la chaîne mentalité des phoques
et des fois je regarde des shows télé je
vois des femmes peut pas qu'ils disent
ou qui a fait ça ça se fait plus dense
et aujourd'hui je trouve que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
puis tout l'équipement de stirling
mouvement il y avait ceux qui dans sa
jeunesse à tout le monde en parle qui
avait comme un enfant oui c'était débile
un choix qui raconté que dans son pot
fait un documentaire avec comme un
enfant soit 2 comme égal de 7 ans qui
était qui est étrange c'est que lui est
fait non jeune femme il est comme tout
le monde dans son entourage
c'est fou je n'ai pas écouté en laissant
son documentaire métier c'est l'histoire
de thé la fit a dit qu'à révéla sa
marque et qatofin mt puis sam
lp sa marque parle pas par deux c'est
fou car c'est qui ça à gauche qu'à
briser des familles pour quelque chose
de tout prix d'escrimé qui tu veux dire
et puis je comprends qu'il y ait une
génération qui a été dans son loft à la
religion était tabou ce destin des
mauvais c'était pas bon mettre un crime
on en détruit des familles du camp
capoter nan moi quand j'ai fait mon
kiosque monchy bisexuels quand j'ai fait
mon coming out à mai à mes parents ça a
été simple ça a été un petit peu pour de
début maintenant mais ça a été quand
même plus simple que je pensais j'étais
sûr que vient en fait je pense que c'est
pas demain pour tout le monde mais j'ai
été chanceux d'abord départ
extraordinaire qui m'ont supporté dans
mon débit parfait je t'aime je t'aime et
nomma roitman puis vie nomade
je pense que c'est sûr aujourd'hui même
c'est encore de plus en plus facile je
prends les parents aussi ont en voyant
ce qui se passe avec avec l'ugtt et on
le voit à la télé plutôt depuis seul web
je pense qu'il commence aussi aux autres
à comprendre ce que les jeunes veulent
puis l'ouverture des jeunes puis mes
parents rajeunissait way libération des
générations si je vous dirais on aider
on pourrait être des parents de
l'information n'avait fait d'autres
choix
tout choix permet aux victimes étaient
des enfants d'où on veut on veut adapter
aussi on saporta bon nous autres on veut
on y lit à voudrait avoir comme cette
fin comme des bonbons commencé avec un
17e et bruce bochy du bois mais je veux
je m'en sers une grande famille
3 minimum ça c'est sûr je trouve que
c'est tellement le tag me ferait sans
lui y était la seule dans sa famille
fait qu'un mot tu t'en dis j'aurais aimé
savoir un petit frère whims s'en fiche
luanda la jeu qui joue ce terrain puis
quand on qu'on fasse des nippes ce n'est
sans labour une pie ton jeu que les
animaux tige
c'est juste c'était pas en même temps je
sais que ce service est comme le step de
10 t à 20 que les enfants arrivent dans
l'équation est en relation mais si un
jour tu aies pu retirer puis ouais ça
fonctionne plus petits le secteur des
fruits pas passer mais des fois t'es
juste pacte avec personne
ça arrive le titre tout semble avoir
trouvé puisque oui je travaille toujours
de travail etc sauf que des fautes et
j'espère que la bonne personne des fois
tu as rencontré une fois que des enfants
dans l'équation même stipulé que cette
personne n'était lié que cette personne
n'en a jamais
signe un contrat que ces personnes là
pour toujours vous avez souligné le nez
qui est pour toujours vous êtes une
équipe le tpiy confiance en lily point
que la journée que je puis avec elle
travaille tu fais que ça m'enlève
tellement pression puis je pense pas à
ça jamais ça mais ça me donne confiance
à georges l'isaf
c'est quelque chose on s'en parlait
dernièrement c'est en ce moment
j'y pense beaucoup parce que je me dis
32 30 30 moi je me dis là j'en veux pas
sûr que si je pourrais en avoir
ça va être j'aimerais ça que ce soit pas
trop tu en fais que me dit mettons que j
en veux pas mais c'était une ambiance
mais c'est parce que je me dis je me dis
moi j'aimerais ça que quand mon cas mon
enfin va avoir 15 ans
j'aimerais ça être capable de kippa
poule m veepee de liberté qu encore à
cours speed est capable d'être c'est que
ce soit aux outils fait peu importe que
ce soit un petit greenstream peu importe
mais juste que je sois capable d'être
avec mon enfant actifs encore tpiy fait
que je me dis trente à quarante cinq
cantons enfants 15 ans puis je me dis je
suis pas superman que je veux dépasser
ça tangue seul garde en forme qui m'ont
alors qu'il s'est passé mais l'enjeu
c'est sauf qu'en même temps c'est
qu'après ceci il ya quand même un bon
gable générationnel aussi mais
l'intelligence que top et h quelques
portes et avec le petit quand même des
kanaks trope amenons goethe et et elsa
apprendre balle à l'arrière juin quand
même être est plus proche de mon enfance
et je me dis si je pourrais en avoir
je prends à mort ça va pas être à 40 1
ça va possiblement est à 35 autour de 35
puis le plus tôt serait mieux tout sauf
qu'en ce moment j'avais pas fait comme
un peu dans une zone de calmes mais pas
trop savoir tpiy moi mettons dans
l'équation partenaires pour avoir un
enfant qui est tout à fait confortable
d'adopter un enfant seul et ongles à
mener c'est ce que je veux faire ça
donne quand même temps même si je dois
adopter en plus je veux pas faire genre
hey je veux absolument trouver une mère
l'autisme et on le sait qu'il y en ait
joué un enfant je vais pas essayer de se
retrouver une mère mettons farah qui
logent pas en coupe il faut choix en
coupe puis je veux trouver de m'arrêter
au besoin si je pouvais vouloir un
enfant mais n'en vaut vraiment la peine
enfin parce que je connais pas ça mais
ça doit être plus difficile d'adopter un
enfant je pense que c'est là
probablement moins probablement mais ça
se fait ça se fait je pense que si je
suis pour avoir ce cas l'anglais ça va
être plutôt plus tard mais pour
l'instant j'en ai pas envie mais chez
que je vois pas si ble ment en avant et
après tu sais comme le clinquant de la
personne 6 assists
on a eu je peux mais pas muet comme 20 2
[Musique]
2 qu'ils voient ça c'est sûr que ça ça
m'intéresse la morgue comme phc pas ses
polos la ccpo dans les prochaines années
mais
c'est le jeune blonde ça le vrai métier
genre ni loin pas la discussion et puis
ça
encore une fois j'ai l'impression que si
c'est la bonne personne puis si c'est
pour se faire à manille naturellement on
va voir conversations impliquant été
mais mais je pense que je pense que j'en
veux mais le jeu veut sa peau je me sens
encore genre pour enraciner qu'importe
ça encore un peu le ti a travaillé fort
le pin tout d'abord faire chez nous
bâtir quelque chose raconte train de
bâtir quelque chose mais je pas encore
installé et puis je quand je vois est
installée que je vois je voudrais que ça
va être un petit peu plus surfer sur ce
que j'ai construit le yaourt au meilleur
moment
mais la star je fais juste imaginer en
ce moment mon rib de vitylo jtg toute la
halle à la carrière en guillemets
podcast audio de ce qui l'amusé que
j'essaie de faire un parallèle juste
comme sujet de diabate à emprunter genre
à ce moment puis je me vois pas
sacrifier un ou l'autre puis avoir un
enfant c'est une tablette en principe
oui t'as glavany et des choix qui vaudra
sa femme est exposé quelques pas l'autre
mais je pense que je pense que ben
muslima même si ça va être drôle à la
fois que tu es venu tu venais de sortir
le clip de keeping mire la frma ça passe
il ya les choses se sont passées le
monde sait que les plats complètement
blow up tiraient dessus comme ça c'est
un game challenger pour tous dans toute
ta carrière toutes les villes d'art fois
il venait de sortir long on en parlait
un peu de sang neuf cent mille
le 55 millions et milieu c'est ça la
vidéo live keeping the thief qui s'est
passé mais sa blouse et fayyoum dur
alors non je pense que c'est un mélange
de ski havel dans le vidéoclip qui m a
fait résonner encore de ce piano
[Musique]
manifesté samedi - on a pris un petit
café puis on habile décembre puis de
voir que sa place et je pense cette
semaine c'est vraiment cool qui malade
mercredi youtube le christ de
plateformes les artistes tc c'est
magnifique de sa propre âge la musique
partout à travers le monde c'est fou
mais cgg obligée d'engager une équipe
brésil ou states
je pense qu'il y avait des femmes
véhicules y est reparti en tournée comme
tour du monde à cause de ta cause un
vidéo you to man si jamais le sopi c'est
si magnifique métier à un juge confiant
je suis pas prêt à baisser dans les
mains des gens aussi des tripes et puis
de vibe alex a pu le voir chercher une
chaire piger j'emmène confondues ont
fait chorégraphie de danse / sur time
chaque jour même des synthés genre 5 6
vidéos de personnes qui danse magie du
ballet j'avais je savais pas à quel
point que la danse est importante dans
ce que je faisais maintenant je réalise
que je veux mettre beaucoup plus de
danse dans ma musique
puis je peux moi je vais commencer à
discuter avec des danseurs je mets ton
pour keep it be alive quelle game vient
puis danse pour cet honneur ou lost ou
allah veut pas ce que j'ai fait
vidéo que les poussées avec l'os puis
gym ou de la danse ou si la d'enppi
express aux flambeaux la façon que les
gens bougent pièta près de ta chanson
tes paroles et puis c'est ça on dirait
que c' est allé chercher ça aller
chercher beaucoup de gens dans la danse
ça a un sens je pense c'est ça le salon
et d'énormément le fait qu'il ya eu de
la danse pluie dense et dans le début du
clip je pense que ça devait exploser une
grosse partie qui explosent à cause de
lui enfin qu'il ya nique géant et annick
merci beaucoup
je l'utilisé aussi pour l'argent noir
est magnifique c'est tellement de bonnes
personnes puis talentueux c'est comme tu
dis oui merida peines et je sais plus si
je te le dis mais j'ai déjà fait la
première partie
ça fait longtemps mais je devais avoir 7
ans betty c'est pas moi métier
d'accompagnant jamais moche que j'ai
trente 30 jours local mis d'accord non
c'était pas capitale c'était dur j'ai
peut-être sept ou dix huit ou max 19 mai
stand et première geek que j'avais pagny
j'accompagnais une chanteuse toute la
connaissais pas vraiment dur ces pistes
et références plutôt depuis c'était une
petite salle à charles beau dans le
trait carré et lte et f à s'entraîner
j'ai tu vraiment aux states et quand
même aux grandes salles tu avais un
guitariste de blues le corps d'un
guitariste de blues avec toi vite et
c'était bon métier y avait peut-être
vingt personnes il faut commencer
quelque temps maintenant mais c est
pareil commencer chaumet barbe d'un
saint-hubert d'un petite salle
communautaire de charlesbourg avec avec
tout le la marde qui venait avec toi
c'est ceci [ __ ] avec toute la marque
que te manger à cause de tout ça c'est
pas si longtemps si toi le petit gamin
20 perd 50 5 millions d'euros sont fous
ces cds bien le cycle commence à faire
débat tant que je faisais tous les
jeudis soirs aux cases bord d'un tank
est à côté de la période
ces jeunes soir avec cruise je pense
peut-être encore trouvé société nommée
mais sur des trames sonores comme du
kerry qui mène c'était mon pays je
comprends pas mais c'est hamilton puis
je tripais pts après sa série
saint-hubert passé festival peine voir
que franck images rapides ici des filets
que j'en souris avec moi monkey oui
j'avais saint-ybars à chaque soir on
avait marqué parce que je m'étais pour
un gars que ça fait somme toute pas si
longtemps qu'il fait si ça paraissait tv
du talent texte avait de quoi qu'ils
quittaient naturel pastilles justement
tu étais tu étais jeune certaine candeur
qui je suis pas tu devais chanter un
plus de jeu en jouant au hockey ou un
petit je pense mais si ça se voyait
qu'il avait gagné ce jeu goyi comprend
rien et qui crispe radicaux de chant
pendant 10 ans puis il faut encore le
tri parce que tu voyais qu'ils veulent
quoi qu'il se passe elle y chantera y
chante bailly est après bt bientôt
laisse une scène intime qui fait que ça
se voyait déjà qu'il se passait mal et
j'ai mis ko l'ismans beaucoup d'or la
[Musique]
gema passion pis je sais à tous les
jours c'est quoi on essaie constamment
d'évoluer de de sauvegarde et de
s'écouter puis trouver on travaille
c'est notre passion ces malades comme
comme comme job dit
je me considère chanceux des catcheurs
qui disent déjà qu'ils voulaient faire
de la musique où il faut avant tout
j'avais je m'appelais des kings john may
be my baby boom mais fox alamo pour
l'écriture puis limogés commencer le jeu
tripes et la tuque après semaine je
pense que plus ce que je vois à la télé
que je voulais comme i want to music
c'était le désir d'être filmé ça au
début qui devenus des offres
d'abonnements puis j'aimais aussi la
leur mieux mais le gramme d'or c'est
comme un coup magnifique les faits
dégueulasses qui tripent sur ta musique
si calmes et lesieu toucher à ceux de
gaza s'est mis à lever mettons les
clameurs de la vie de faire de la
musique est en jeu parce que je me mets
dans le sens le puy le vécu battu vie
mais tu es maintenant j'ai l'impression
que tu étais toute petite vie un peu
plus grand je m'étais installée totale
et jacques villeneuve est extrêmement
divisé dans notre occident madame non
mais où est ce que quelqu'un était signé
tekori wright le chile pleine vitesse
quand même c'est quand même gros stress
quand même des baies loin
je ne sais pas comment je vois ça
aujourd'hui l'apprécient je tripe j'ai
du fun mais c'est ça fait comme pour
montrer que ça devient de plus en plus
normal ce que je fait rire puis je
rendrai j'ai trouvé un bal avec la
maison que j'ai acheté 3 6e tour me
garder c'est selon direct conflit chez
madame côté de truc me prenait pour un
autre puis il coache immature puis jetée
jeunes qui jetaient comblement com ou
s'ils ne sont pas beaucoup d'expérience
je rentre dans un milieu uk
à cause de nos rois fin cui ça on dirait
que vu que gives vu que mon débutait pas
normal piste est comme un peu le waouh
appartement c'est sûr que tu trouvé
comme le respect de ces deux-là jobs
[Musique]
puis aussi pour zeman du monde travaille
en tabarnak pour certains ou t'es rendu
tout ça fait dix jours que dans
l'industrie même style de jeu c'est pas
normal mais faute puis après ça basset
substitut
avec l'expérience puis des choses que je
sais ton juin pie ix et cory c'est sûr
qu'après ça tapera beaucoup plus
strictes juste guillemot débat dropping
[ __ ] tu t'amuses à d'un petit enlève ta
c'est d'enlever le nickel de trouver des
quinze jours medjo par exemple ton club
tu sors de ton clés pour l'osce mais là
tu ns est une l'envoyer en première
enfin quand on va le tchèque et live
puis on invite les gens on va faire
jouer ici probablement ont reproché à
trac sonore par-dessus fait que vous
allez pas bien le voir mais allez
l'écouter parce qu'il est sorti le clip
zettel a fait la chose qui était plus
fort que tu as fait cette offre aussi
parce qu'avec les confinements piliers
une nouvelle règle qui est depuis trouvé
du monde en une minute
tous les matins m'attire matelly à
montréal qui en fait une job incroyable
avec une idée que j'avais même dit j'ai
assez de rajouter plein de petites
erreurs qui m'a fait mon job débile pour
les poules et puis les arrangements tu
sais que c'est toi d'alphonse ssb est
une combinaison comme tout le monde qui
a fait une crise de belle job de texter
je la regarde puis je suis pas je sens
mon nom mais je suis vraiment riche fia
magie on a travaillé fort tapez une kg
racheter de la danse l'hégire ajouter
des strings je voulais je tends du
talent au québec de suite maintenant
gothique stehlik entre les mains celui
de même que fait quand kevin mirallas
même machine
on est ensemble qu'un puis là on va voir
ce que ça dit à fin mai on était
ensemble quand kim d'appeler pour parler
de la finale la tonne puis le studio on
pourrait peut-être faire un genre de
planning et pis c'est une perfo la
transat était ce texte un clip sur une
quittance la façon qu'on compte comme
qui paye mes lèvres comme toutes les
vidéos que j'ai postée sur youtube et on
sait tout du live cd one take on le fait
à peu près neuf fois puis on prend la
meilleure tech
je trouve ce trip à face à comme ce
parce que ça pousse à être parfait puis
beaucoup de monde là dedans puis aussi
la caméra fac-ci la caméra phoques mais
on peut pas le prendre même si le duo
est parfaitement qu'il ya beaucoup qui
vient en ligne de compte pisser ces
familles en adrénaline des fois en plus
un petit brun pain par fait pire en
scolaire
c'est là ils peuvent maintenant
henry
[Musique]
[Musique]
i
l'église à bas des moments là
[Musique]
paul j
nous les suivons niveau
auxquels il faut le croire avant les
chemises rouges pour vous en
[Musique]
j'ai le coeur de pleigne offrir
non
[Musique]
je souris yon ti
ap
[Musique]
m
son match terne et si l'espèce
[Musique]
qu'aux femmes souffrant d'une forme
de croo
reste posée aux femmes
suite
qui selon moi on est pour
oui
le volet non
avant
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
zizou il
puis
et nouveauté
[Musique]
m
monsieur
[Musique]
oh
coc
[Musique]
innsbruck il faut les leprince avant les
jalousies omar sy au nord
[Musique]
j'ai joué
l'église est mais le l'éclairage qui
passe de sous c'est un clip de marie mai
qui a été comme dans une pensée je
décolle chez beaucoup hadopi j'écoutais
ce pays j'ai vu comme l'église a capoté
suspect j'appelle mon jeu dark angels
puis le lieu qui était parfait les tout
le monde même si ce compte et c'est
tellement le fun quand évitée comme ce
cadre et noir maintenant cette crise
puis peut-être réaliser tout semaine
puis muscade mats ek order qui marquent
moins d beaucoup même si j'avais c'est
la première fois que j'avais autant que
j'ai pris autant de place pour les
danses à travailler que hôte de caisse
khalef dans ces lacs m
le dio tout c'est la première fois que
je mettais autant de temps pis
normalement je laisse les gens faire
leurs armes et fait que j'ai hâte de
voir qu'est ce que ça va faire sur
youtube en même temps aucun cas la
partie
on va savoir c'est quoi la réception
c'est sur la réception est
extraordinaire maintenant appréciable
aux insultes il ya plusieurs affaires
qui rentrent en ligne de compte qu'une
vidéo cinq ans est exact que j'ai déjà
fait un show avec on avait engagé
j'avais un show avec les projets avec
mon ex copine voit le jour au festival
de jazz de lévis tv qu'on avait comme
prix et thoune nous tourner qui on a
donné d'avery arrangé pour ce soir
c'était une bonne expérience
les gars premièrement il a dit que les
plus drôles que gérant conduire ce
malade pige à la fête une répète et puis
où est ce qu'ils ont fait à première
toune ces puits ont fait ok que du genre
de la section notre fraîcheur au tibet
genre passe pas comme tu on peut se dire
là dessus des 25 gratitude on arrive au
chaud on commence le show première toune
on arrête en section seuls ou par mail
mais genre fait un solo de jean cinq
semaines le drama bénisse amy
décapotable déjà après une tendance au
regard des genres qu'est-ce qui viennent
ce club et celle à qui ça va être le fun
comme chose limoges
mostafa el hadj aïssa marché il sera bon
mais il peut se perdre tabarnak s'ils
veulent me pousser dans l'enclos aux
yeux bac ok mais ça fait gaza fait 7,8 à
colmar qui m
quel commentaire j'aime ta qu'a laissé
réputation 18 ans qui se monte à la
chandelle mon premier album sort toutes
les bacs
ok après ça on s'est revu avec moi je
pense mon deuxième album aussi apprécié
coureurs dont le fait des affaires avec
kim qui me fait à chanter avec cory sur
des enfants
j'ai tout a vraiment connecté avec ma
fille je suis vraiment la queen sol à
montréal nous voit manie blanc on peut
aller voir sur youtube il ya d'autres
vidéos de quelques mots qui chantent
ensemble est magnifique qu'est ce
qu'elle fait pour moi 6,1 me fais aider
à faire moi je parle de faire piquer
marie fait pire en semaine et qu'elle
allait oui je voudrais casse comme ça se
prépare t on pas ce congé comme changer
l'arrangement deux jours avant le
tournage je pense trop chauvin dans une
soirée mais tête brûlée tide maintenant
matelas comme à minuit mama jaune et je
trouve pas ma mère estime sa mare avec
sommes oubliés sont celles dans le char
est en panique je pense que je pourrais
peut-être pas être le jeter comme kim
relaxe cette amère votre chum pas de
stress tepa lost est pas là mais
finalement ça m'a raté quelques avait
oublié de téléphone dans le chat mais
chiba à la mène de quad extraordinaire à
notre banc depuis c'est sûr que je pars
en tournée n'importe qui mais la queen
femmes sur la queen du cheesecake
médiamat avec la avec la pandémie est là
elle avait moins de gala start and
business de chip est 600 fois qu'elle
aura même si la pandémie le terrain mais
bon beaucoup de monde j'ai fait mystic
joy soit on à l'école nous avons trouvé
nos jobs pique pas sûr que ça va
repartir faculté faut collectivement
mais innovent où trouver une façon notre
passion pour faire un petit peu d'argent
où elle avait payé la choisissait pas
tripette mais n'at elle pas facilement
astiquer le plus facile depuis surtout
en daim noir d'être une fille dans ce
temps là la machine d'être encore là
dedans aujourd'hui un chapeau à cette
femme
avez-vous des fours est prévue
je suis prêt oui je pense d'outreau
festival plus en plus mal les mesures
commencent à cela ainsi fait fort
sûrement juge pourtant tout new york que
fin juin dix festival f1 team et toi
quelques monde de boules ça va pas 2000
il pas jusqu'à 2000 personnes je fais
que oui bah écoute on vos sites web et
sa gamme à la russie qu'on va annoncer
les choucas qui vont quand tu m'en être
annoncée mais oui ça doit être ça fait
du bien ça me manque j'ai je réalise
avec mon parce que plus le temps de
tourner maintenant j'ai une grande
partie par tout pigé réalise à quel
point que sam l'adrénaline de la scène
mais nous sommes vraiment très
puissamment qui chu teh afghane
je laisse en amont je vois dans mon
comportement ma patience un joie de
vivre la sexualité à ma mort d'anne
anita une vague géante que ça repart
pour pouvoir me retrouver davantage mais
c'est quand même pris trois ans ou que
la première fois je me suis découvert
comme individu en or du sport et de la
musique
me fait du bien crise mais logitech
sommes prêts pour le choc de la figure 2
go puis finalement naniwa a été
perpétrée mine parce que ça nous a
permis de racheter pleine affaire de ma
business c'est moi de contrôler ma
business la coban discret c'est j'avais
des enfants j'avais besoin de mettre en
place fait que ça m'a permis d'avoir ce
temps le pot farce pour après ça doit
être super créatif mais déjà en train
d'écrire le prochain album
c'est ça mais là dans le fond tu es
tombé sur le 28 fait que les gens ont
pour l'écouté aussi en écoutant ses
sorties sur main on invite les gens
l'écoutent et bitume a fait entendre
déjà des tracks de l'hôte album qui s'en
vient ouais c'est jeter jouer c'est bon
c'est bon c'est un autre genre
complètement ailleurs
va-t-on rapt un tas d'objets trouvés
j'ai retrouvé mon sens ça va évoluer
tsavo vad et puis en même temps ma voix
c'est ce qui va garder ton pied 300
tonnes qui existe là des efforts
notables malgré tout le talent et un
ouais mais le gg j'ai jamais pris pour
un à mener mais je ramenais j'écrivais
une tonne par jour
des fois de petits pas complètement vers
ce même se valent avait juste des jo
d'hiver score sj garde des fois mais ça
va arriver que j'ai une session
maintenant avec quelqu'un d'autre qui a
besoin d'une tonne me voir je prends de
csd le pot pour cette personne aussi
c'est bon tout ce qu'est layton pour
d'autres wael ça m'a fait changer deux
proches d'eux trop chanson sur son
dernier album puis hudson j'ai vraiment
eu du fun à écrire pour quelqu'un
d'autre j'ai fait aussi ça m'échappe le
[Musique]
met à nu et bébé jeffery lau rafale roi
raphaël 3 500 graphiques à kindu la
marche
c'est fou piché c'est ça je veux on veut
finalisation avec lg j'aime ça j'aime
c'est l'fun décret puis créé des
mélodies des paroles pour tout le monde
de voir que ça prenne onu enseignement
spat avoir changé la voix ça change
complètement en chemin
c'est fou vient cfoot et même s'ils
changent même pas tant l'arrangement
l'émotion de la tournée le fils
d'acteurs voix change vraiment ces
maisons c'est beau c'est ce petit jeu
rafa peut chanter n'importe quoi
je trouve ça cool quelqu'un c'est mon
père mon idole le voile mais quelqu'un
qui quittait machine j'essaie de chanter
de quoi n'importe quoi puis de le mettre
comme j'ai fait avec believe me 2,6 à la
version fait des années que sortie au
puy moi je me surprends de couacs qui
complètement d'ailleurs de mon bagage
puis en même temps c'est ça pour
quelqu'un d'autre en dehors de ce qu'ils
font peut-être daily mail indique moi je
vais créer qui sont faites pour moi
vérité mais ils prennent je trouve ça
cool quelqu'un qui est capable vraiment
qu'il y avait je peux attaquer les
missions qui avait pris justement ces
deux artistes que ça change et des
tonnes cpct jean-marie mips afiane
olympique tpo plus ils ne prennent ils
attendent de l'autre puis tout d'un coup
la tête de mardi était vraiment bien a
fait beaucoup de pays de caux qui
reprend je prends souvent déjà de
tourner un peu quétaine entre guillemets
quétaine années 90-2000 genre est ma
meilleure amie pitcher thérapie avec ces
gens lui même par eux mais juste
interprétation c'est comme une nouveau
centre avait chanté bonne c'était gentil
a chanté bon enfant pas comme si tu sais
pas non rester bon c'est la toute bonne
foi toit puis le séjour à la chambre
mais jean avec son avec son segment
[Musique]
chanson déportée avec sa finale en plus
c'est comme ça
d'où une jambe mais je vais ressentir ça
il ya une autre émission aussi qui est
fait c'est juste sous le web le sait ces
genres y avait pris ses ordres sur quand
l'utiliser québec le tir appuyé
je pense la fif téléachat à gaza par une
chanteuse country de piler charge de
tous ces gens c'est juste drôle de voir
à quel point personne est venue l'idée
chaude musique dttb les bonnes notes ce
mode est très chaude télé de musique
mouvement qui ont ramené les prestations
musicales à tout le monde en parle
depuis chaque semaine des prestations
cellphone je suspendrai qu'avec youtube
njikam ma dose de trucs un petit peu
chez qui des perf au live band triple
menace est rendue a dit que le monde
font était seul incident n'ont pas si si
même ceux ci un respectable à covina
semaines je dirais ça paraît pas
affecter je trouve que on est capable
d'aller reproduire des trucs assez aux
demandes qu'on n'a plus besoin de gros
plateaux de télévision pis c'est un
artiste comme deux modes kennedy qui est
juste sur un piano seul sait filmer puis
ces genres sont vidéo mais ni vu par des
dizaines de millions de personnes juste
parce qu' il est même capable si je
trouve que la musique live ont un accès
à plus il ya plus de monde sont capables
de faire des trucs
un puis t'es pas obligé de paix
d'invités en plateau de télé le total à
star académie
car même je dirais nestes i rode c'est
un homme semaine aux seuls fans puissent
apprendre fois que je faisais un show
que d'autres monde chantait des tonnes
mais pas valmy tournoi puis je trouver
sur ce parcours c'était
flatteur vraiment bien fait ça je
trouvais que je souhaiterais manque ou
et puis des cours dans tout l'album next
time mais j'ai réussi que j'adresse et
des plus les jeunes
gevrey vrai j'ai vraiment tripé le web
puis j'ai trouvé ça le fun ii comme pas
coacher nécessairement là mais du
contenu d'itunes
je voudrais que d'autres sur certaines
affaires puis j'aimerais que tu pourrais
dire à mon équipe parce que j'adore
produits mais l'album je les produits
avec brian j l'expérience des bouquets
les tournées de monter un show de vidéos
de ce train là dedans mais oui mais tu
es alors que son équipe
ouais c'est ça un jugement taux des
bonnes personnes pour pouvoir face avec
une pige à prendre sur le donne moi
c'est ça qui est cool c'est ça c'est ça
l'enjeu principal mais qu'est ce qui
t'inspire des cas écrire mais tout dans
ta vie tu mets ton lorsque le quai c'est
pourquoi le pourquoi lost qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui t'a amené lost mais
maintenant ce sont eux d'en parler le
sens
on a mené sans ricains détox puis j'en
ai parlé si besoin
ça a été un moment c est serov pour pour
lui pis
puis pour nous aussi parce qu'on voit
notre chaîne de cette façon là puis moi
je je connaissais mon job c'était pas
mon job et ça m'a inspiré des crimes a
fait plusieurs tours sur scène ce pas
parce que je voulais être une façon de
l'aider puis en même temps j'avais
besoin de sortir des dix genre de petit
démon gvt et puis là c'est sur une
amitié que je dois être le tout le temps
pour toit mais nombre d'habitants ont
fui ou pinot maroua depuis l'ouest
récemment je m'inspire de tout autour de
moi une quoi qui se perdent en tête des
fois si des fois c'est un mode et fois
ci c'est s'est dit parole des fois ci un
titre de la chanson tout explose la
samba fall est de cesser
je me laisse aller mardi d'un stage pas
ma guide pour ces gens voient ça marc
bouchard jean régis avec marché chez lui
et puis on passe on finalise de toi
vancouver piste un processus maman qui
me fait bien parce que je connais
quelqu'un qui est que beaucoup de bébés
en tête puis la musique me permet
d'aider à la fois kindle en ce sens en
musique
benhamza pas quelqu'un qui suscita que
ce soit mais alors à la musique jeux ça
me va pas pour toi même ça nous fait du
bien de jouer semaine ccc plus beau
métier du monde à tous pour tous et même
pas juste de le jouer mais je m'attends
l'as chez vous le 15 juillet de la
musique qui joue pourtant bien même tu
marches pour aller jusqu'en bout qui
émanait domaine ton accord avec toi tu
es là tu t'amènes ta musique avec là
tout le temps le pij écouter j'écoute
pas cet été chez nous au cutoff john
kennedy passée a fortement mais j'écoute
juste d'instruments ce nom sinon ces
gens les écouter du lot faille par là je
pense à 80 dans la grotte bûcher mais
alors music puis je lis c'est bizarre
parce que je lis je les détester pour
comme un ordre
j'ai voulu surtout les plus abordés
dedans c'est comme s'il avait besoin de
la patte en doutez rendu j'avais jamais
je leur ai pensé demande mais je me suis
rendu le génome du riz puis
éventuellement quand presque quelque six
mois plus tard réaliser que ce qu'ils
meurent me c'est ce qui m'a mis sur la
planète terre nom était péter munk en
avait reçus fressange les associe notre
gu les gatti est à la lutte avec marie
je pense que je pense qu'une star of
pitt il a été lui-même a été 15 ans et
elle a travaillé 12 heures par jour dans
studio à faire des tonnes tout le temps
de toute l'attention qu'ils aiment en
plus puis si après ça y est fait comme
toi y est parti en vente
[Musique]
parce que je voulais aller écrit avec
lui pillet de devic il disait au début
même pas des types de musique d'avant
c'est comme vous voulez plus bénéfique
sur comment et thierry dromard jarre
dati à l'époque c'était comme pas sûr
qu'ils allaient refaire la musique le
temps qui est et kerman et ça revient
scam à nice et ses petits yeux le côté
sipa la musique comme tel c'est
l'industrie où ces tirs ou et c'est
juste le fait d'être of the work mais la
musique comme tel c'est bon maintenant
on est en y passant ces boues s'il
s'agit pas que les gens qui écoutent de
la musique va pas nous dit pas censé le
mais je trouve que on y passe en ciblant
nous avons tous besoin de tout le monde
a hâte d'y tenir le coup et we have to
be puis des fois on se laisse emporter
par surtout parce qu'on aime tellement
son pic à concasser chi ça va pas la
façon qu'on veut mais petit on met
tellement darleux dans le sort de
copines mais n'ont ni mpossible cru il
ya des boîtes et idées là je pense que
ça va le marché on a faim j'aime quand
même un moment où mon père mais comme
dit à sa femme un homme un fait rare
mais be my baby les constats voyage une
croissance un clip j'ai pu que jusque
dans ce 5ème en retournant jouer au sein
du bar estime encore l'espagnol face à
de ma vie à la vie à la vie
je veux juste je vois balance ému mon
art ces défauts ce test était fou
maintenant j'en tourné à côté à travers
le canada madd date après date après
date entrevue après entrevue c'est toute
entrevue par jour 9 entrevue par jour de
la présente un show ça te prend l'avion
à 00h07 au report puis je vois juste
gérer mieux mon temps pour garder la
bible c'est ce que d'autres sont quand
même bien si un jet privé seul mais
quand même parce que toute l'attention
sur soi
maintenant de créer une structure où est
ce que ton propre boss mais métier
maintenant juste des jeux des trucs qui
est chez nous tu y mets ton mari lou qui
était venu ici c'est sur l'entourage
départ de ta carrière trémie titouan tu
vois pas bien où six ou sept à huit
heures de show ressembler aux autres et
veulent continuer
c'est sûr que l'entourage à biville pose
notamment est arrivé à certains niveaux
est ce que tu mets tes limites métier
c'est ce qui a amené son entourage peut
toujours tourner ton intérêt personnel
du comment quand tu veux
psychologiquement à car le but c'est de
ces c'est l'artiste la business l'été
avant l'artiste la personne puisse y
sommes c'est comme si des fois mené on
oublie moi j'avais comme oublié pourquoi
je faisais de la musique
oui on a tous cru en ce sens on tombe
dans ce bateau-là de sûreté que des
grosses compagnies si gt5 avec le musée
pied mais mène ses se sont oubliés tu
étais tellement fier d'une tonne sur
l'envoi leur pourvoir savoir faire
l'album c'est vrai que voir soit choisir
ton album s'est placé un tel goût de
choisir des 5 tonnes ou des huit tonnes
que soi même ce ton et pipi moi je
trouve ça plate d'amener des tonnes et
des tonnes puis non non non ok
l'art de sang les make me feel good à
moins d'un an des arbres de gérard py
ginette qui décide des questions
cependant même une attitude qui fait que
je trouve que je trouve que l'industrie
musicale
je changeais beaucoup mais je trouve
qu'ils vont ça va commencer à les
supporter des artistes vont commencer à
mettre le pied à la réalité si tu le
vois avec toutes les
les artistes qui ont réussi qu'à qui ont
vraiment mis leur pied à terre de 2 6 me
belle leçon comme jamais mais quand tu
commences à douter un petit peu mais le
son sont moins embarquée fait qu'ici
c'est parce que lippi continent écrit
tout à fait qd il y en aura qui s'est
passé 5e album vent on a offert dix neuf
à douze treize quatorze albums fait que
mène à 200 on en avait mis en avant un
style plutôt tpiy c'est mon coup tu nous
quittes un journaliste qui les a menés
dit je passe les jeunes en un détecteur
à la bouche est semaine puis ça marche
en musique ou swissair des trucs
formater les trucs que tu vois que ça
vient pas des tripes mais ça vient d'une
recette où tout se on est quand même pas
ça ça parait être simple pige or les
artistes qui fonctionne c'est sous ce
qu'ils font tout pour des bonnes raisons
souvent au départ le sait la plupart le
tc ce qui fit qu'écrit avec leurs tripes
qui font qu'ils qui sont eux qui m
brasse leur singularité
ce qui fait que qui sont mémorables aux
6 0 il ya ceux qui sait ce qu'on veut
puis je trouve que c'est que c'est bien
ce que je pensais pas parfait mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils passent que la radio
décidé ou six
si les autres et encore maintenant j'ai
pas été capable d'avoir du québec sur
une radio impassible
ouais ben rabah mais c'est sur un
médecin mais transposé fight certains
types de musique qui fait mieux dans tel
type de prêt encore du monde qui se pose
à sa playlist piano instrumental l'islam
parce que c'est pas la face et comme
instagram c'est qu'on savait mais c'est
tout tu peux payer aussi pour apparition
des playlists pcc dit jean qui rit plus
du lobbying grosses compagnies et les
autres machines mais au moins quelqu'un
qui est pas d'un grosse machine peut
tirer son épingle du jeu
quelqu'un qui dise times qui a annoncé
la bonne nouvelle dans tout seul ouais
je pense travail forte et authentique
même pied
c'est fait on enfin je pense que ça ils
n'ont rien dit quand tu t'entoures de
bonnes personnes c'est sûr que
maintenant je me suis dit jamais je veux
signer qu'un gros mais john est bon des
fois je me dis ah mais c'est pierre les
parents perdent le contrôle de de
massmart quelque chose de quelque chose
qu'il faut bien ses mannequins en garden
je m'exprime german toujours un plaisir
certain plaisir ce job sympa c'est oui
maintenant pas non 50
merci mario jean puis vous avez partie
comme je le dis à ph même je trouve que
vous avez particulièrement débile on est
aujourd'hui ce quelque chose qu'on
aurait jamais tout est dit
merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin de ce père que vous avez
apprécié les conversations ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de cas
si l'on vous remercie vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passe hier sur
petra non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde pétulant
nous aussi on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page rituels et le lien vers ce havre
dans la description du podcast fait
qu'il remercie encore une fois nous
avons écouté jusqu'à la fin